okay so here we go
cars yeah everybody liked this movie
when it came out and I'll just be honest
I don't get it this seemed like the
biggest step backwards you could take
for a studio that was doing so well why
because the last film they did finally
start human characters you would think
that this would open up the door for so
many more stories so many more
opportunities but no now it's cars okay
what was it cars that come to life and
people get inside them no it's just a
world where everything's a car what well
okay maybe this just opens it up for a
lot of creative jokes because as we all
know everybody really knows a lot about
cars actually hell even if you do know a
lot about cars are there really that
many car jokes in this okay let's go to
the beginning you got a race car played
by Owen Wilson he's a big celebrity
hotshot constantly winning all the races
in the stadiums filled with cars got
this is weird okay while he's being
transported to his next big race he
accidentally gets lost and gets stuck in
a town that he accidentally destroys a
good portion of the court decides that
the best way for him to pay for his
crime is for him to fix up what he did
of course being the egotistical hotshot
he just wants to get to his race but the
town won't let him leave until he
accounts for his actions so while taking
responsibility he comes across a couple
colorful characters a pickup truck
played by Larry the Cable Guy a hippie
van played by the late George Carlin and
a romantic interest played by Bobby Hunt
gee will he discover that hard work and
responsibility is really what's
important will he discover that there's
actually some charm to the small town
locations will they look at things in a
different point of view that'll make him
more humble and a nicer guy in the end
does that engine light mean something's
wrong with your vehicle I don't know
because I don't care about cars and I
don't know a lot of people that really
do either
I mean sure there's people obsessed with
cars and they like to make him look good
but making them the focus of a movie
this is really
you weird but even taking that out of it
this story has been done to death and it
doesn't seem like they're really adding
anything new outside of just making
people cars I think I laughed at one
joke in this entire movie and that's
where there's a lineup in the female
bathroom okay that got a laugh out of me
but aside from that nothing
I didn't crack a smile once it was
boring it was tedious it was long it
didn't look that great it's a dumb
concept it's boring characters I okay I
know a lot of people like this film I
know it's sold a lot of toys and I guess
it makes sense hot wheels and stuff sell
really well now actually put eyes and a
smile on that Hot Wheel and bada-bing
you probably have a good seller but as a
story and character goes this didn't do
a thing for me in my opinion this was
the first really big Pixar
disappointment but a lot of people seem
to go see it and enjoy it I don't know
too many people who see it as their
favorite but they seem to like it okay
and I guess as always there's nothing
really bad in it for kids and to its
credit the ending actually is a very
nice heartwarming ending but I still
don't know why this movie was made why
was this considered a good concept why
did people think it was creative why did
people enjoy the characters and the
story that they've seen a bajillion
times that didn't really add anything
that new to it I don't know then maybe
I'll never know but it was still a big
hit both the audiences and critics seem
to enjoy it so I'll just shut up and let
you enjoy what you enjoy but for me all
I'm thinking in my mind is come back
Brad Bird come back
you